a prime minister trying to take back
control of her party her program her
policy agenda
[Laughter]
a moment of levity but she knows what's
at stake the cost of that massive U-turn
could be huge but for now no regrets
frankly the 45p wasn't a priority policy
and I listened to people and I think
there's there's absolutely no shame Beth
in a leader listening to people and
responding and that's the kind of person
I am and I've been totally honest and
upfront with people but it everything
I've done as prime minister is focused
on helping people get through what is a
very difficult winter is Liz just going
to survive to the end of the year Mr
Dave but questions about how she'll get
through this winter with her back
benches in Revolt Home Secretary swella
bravman on the front bench unhappy too
ultimately I'm very disappointed that
members of our own parliamentary party
uh staged a coup effectively and
undermined the author authority of the
Prime Minister in an unprofessional way
we are one party
support benefit
that coup will likely continue Penny
mordant and other cabinet ministers past
and present do we need to upgrade
benefits in line with inflation do you
agree with colleagues on that now split
over whether benefits should rise in
line with inflation or not
the policy decided by the last Prime is
to upgrade benefits with inflation you
don't seem minded to do that we haven't
made a decision on that issue yet I
think voters are just tired of a lack of
honest answers I'm just saying to you're
not minded to do it of course we will
make the decision on the benefits
operating in due course but that
decision has not yet been made what you
what you want to do or you just you're
generally ambivalent I'm not ambivalent
I am focused on the issue at hand
the issue though is ambivalence outside
this room from within her own party on
the issue of um uplifting benefits by
inflation or earnings what would you
like to see happen because it's a bit of
a division over it well it's a decision
that will be made collectively in the
normal way that government decisions are
made I haven't seen any papers on it I
don't believe a decision has been made
but it's understandably a question that
people are asking
not just asking but arguing about it
former cabinet colleagues on Fringe
events of this conference subtly hinting
the government should make the shift if
you were the chancellor would you
upright welfare benefits in line with
inflation or would you be more cautious
so I think right now along with the
wider reforms that have been outlined on
supply side etc etc there is an
opportunity to actually get some of
these policies right and that means
supporting people giving people the
support that they need in terms of
getting to work getting the jobs but
giving them the financial support as
well where it is needed what's your
message to some of your back benches sir
no reply tough times for this cabinet
and their pm
prime minister you've been in power for
28 days but 10 of those politics was
paused in 18 days then you announced 45
billion pounds of tax cuts without
setting a fiscal framework the pound
Tanked a thousand mortgage deals
withdrawn from the markets you
established a 33-point lead for labor in
the polls and now the lady not for
turning has announced a massive u-turn
on a policy this is surely the worst
start of any prime minister well let's
remember what we were facing four weeks
ago but you expect we were facing
families having energy bills of up to
six thousand pounds and what we have
done as a government is acted decisively
swallow Bradman what's your message to
MPS and infighting what would you like
to say to them
thank you so much
but that is an uphill task the polls are
terrible the party's disunited and this
PM's in trouble tomorrow Liz trust will
make her fast leader speech a lot is at
stake Beth Rigby Sky News Birmingham